>> ♪ ♪
>> Bret: WELL, IT'S BEEN A LONG
WEEK.
NOTABLE QUOTABLES?
>> THE STATE OF OUR UNION IS
STRONG.
>> I HAVE NOT SEEN SO MANY STONE
FACES IN AN AUDIENCE SINCE
EASTER ISLAND.
>> THAT'S NOT JUST BERNIE
SANDERS'S BOOK.
>> IT'S ONE QUESTION YOU ASK
OVER AND OVERAGAIN.
WHAT KEEPS NANCY PELOSI UP AT
NIGHT?
>> NUNES IS A STOOGE FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE TO DO ALL OF THIS.
>> AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES WERE
ABUSED.
THAT NEED TO COME TO LIGHT.
>> I THINK MR. McCABE HAS BEEN
DEEPLY AND UNFAIRLY MALIGNED.
>> THANKS, OBAMA.
>> INSTEAD OF A HAND OF
>> DO IT RIGHT.
>> THEY TALK A GOOD GAME WITH
DACA.
BUT THEY DON'T PRODUCE.
>> I AM A PERSON, HEART AND
SOUL.
HOPES AND DREAMS.
>> AMERICANS ARE DREAMERS TOO.
>> IT'S A SCENE YOU DON'T WANT
TO EVER SEE.
THERE IS A LOUD BANG AND THINGS
TEACHING A BUNCH OF 17 YEARS OLD
THIS?
>> WELL, THE GUY OUGHT TO GO TO
HELL.
>> A LOCKER ROOM FULL OF GUYS
READY FOR THE DHNGE
READY FOR THE DHNG
READY FOR TEA DHNG
READY FOR TE
READY FOR THE
READY FOR THE CH
READY FOR THE CHAL
READY FOR THE CHALLE
READY FOR THE CHALLENG
READY FOR THE CHALLENGE.
>> OH, BOY.
>> SOME PEOPLE TAKE IT TO THE